in this course I hope we can capture
some of Walt Whitman's enthusiasm for
the strong light works of Engineers so
we explore the great structures of every
era from an engineering perspective
let's begin our journey with a visit to
a structure that's indisputably one of
the world's greatest the Brooklyn Bridge
when we look at a magnificent work like
this one we see three essential
qualities form function and structure
perhaps the most obvious of these three
is function how people use the bridge
function of the Brooklyn Bridge is to
span the East River linking Brooklyn and
Manhattan originally for pedestrians
horse-drawn vehicles and trolleys but
today for six lanes of automobile
traffic now back in the 1800s that
function was pretty significant and the
economic and social impacts of linking
those two cities was really quite
important today however it's really not
the function but the form that
stimulates our emotions and captures our
imagination
so what's form form refers to as
aesthetic appeal the physical features
of a building bridge are tower-like
shape scale proportion ornament and the
form of the Brooklyn Bridge certainly is
beautiful
the graceful curve of those main cables
the strength and solidity of the granite
towers that intricate web of steel
framework that supports the roadway we
think of these features as being
primarily aesthetic but there's so much
more they are in fact a direct
reflection of the scientific principles
underlying the design of this Great
Bridge they are in a word structure a
system of low carrying elements that
causes the bridge to stand up now to
illustrate this point I'd like to take a
look at a model of a typical suspension
bridge you see here this model consists
of two main cables the cables are
anchored out here on the ends they
extend up over the tops of these two
tall towers and then they're draped
across the main span in that
characteristic curved shape from the
cables you see that I have suspend
did a series of weights there equal
weights and they're all spaced an equal
distance apart so this constitutes a
uniform loading on the cable the shape
of the cable then is a direct
consequence of that loading it's really
a function of physics the shape of the
cable mathematically speaking is a
parabola and the parabola occurs
specifically as a consequence of that
loading it's science not aesthetics I'll
pick the tops of the towers the cable
makes a sharp bend and as a direct
consequence of that Bend all of the
tension in the cable is transmitted
downward into the towers and so in
effect the two towers are carrying the
entire weight of the bridge and
everything that's that's applied to that
bridge in compression directly down
through the towers and that's why on the
Brooklyn Bridge the towers are so
massive there's such robust granite
structures so the parabolic shape of the
curve of the cable is caused by the
uniform loading what happens if the
loading isn't uniform what happens for
example if a vehicle a heavy vehicle
like a train or a heavy truck is
crossing the span well when that heavy
vehicle gets out here to mid span no
what happens
note that the parabolic shape of the
cables has now become distorted into
something very different one of the
characteristic features of a cable
structure is that it changes the shape
in response to changes in applied
loading well that's all well and good
but if this is a functional suspension
bridge we have a problem because that
sort of distortion in the cable also
caused a significant downward deflection
of the deck that the vehicles are
driving across so imagine if you're the
occupant or driver of a vehicle that's
moving from one side of the bridge to
the other when the vehicle is located
here the cable distorts into this shape
as it moves to this location the cable
distorts again but into a different
shape by the time it gets out to mid
span it's distorted into yet another
shape again and all the while the bridge
is undulating and undergoing all these
crazy deformations clearly it's not
practical as a functional structure and
that's why most suspension bridges to
include the Brooklyn Bridge use a
secondary structure called a stiff
Trust which is supported directly from
the cable and I do want to emphasize
that the stiffening trust is not resting
on the towers note that there's a space
between the ends of the truss and the
towers it's entirely hanging from the
cable but now when I take this same
heavy concentrated load of the vehicle
crossing the bridge and we place it on
the stiffening truss we see that the
shape of the cables didn't change at all
but the stiffening trust does is to
distribute that heavy load out laterally
so that all of these slender vertical
wires they're called suspenders carry
that load instead of just one or two
suspenders as you saw in the case of the
unn stiffened deck so what we see is
that all of these prominent aspects of
the form of the Brooklyn Bridge the
shape of the cables the robust stone
towers the stiffening trusses they all
derive from structural purpose as this
demonstration shows we really can't
fully appreciate and understand the
Brooklyn Bridge based on its form and
its function alone we need to see and
understand its structure as what